what everybody we're pond finna tip and
welcome to another episode of challenge
community this the series were you
challenge us with her crazy studies
related to table tennis we'll go through
all of your comments with the most
pretty ones and make a video out of them
if your comment gets picked we'll give
you a shout out and picture in the next
video so leave your comments in the
comment section below
grumpy oh she wants me to block five
dunks with my foot so let's play some
food table tennis
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Twi child was his potential Topsham
rally with Penhall
[Music]
this one's from Julian 47 tried to make
three behind the back around the net
shots in a row okay Julian let's do it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Gary garner wants us to make a call
wheel table tennis shop
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
Kiro Ahmad wants to play with two balls
and the other one has to do around the
back shots and the other one has to do
between the leg shots Nika you can do
the around the back shots and I'll do it
between the elections let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
create is asking is it possible to buy
completely teachers as a matter of fact
we have just opened up our pumpkins in
merchandise store so now you can indeed
be one of the first people ever to buy
it and get yourself one of these or one
of these so you can find the store at
print motor comm slash pom phenotype and
there is link in description below make
sure you check it out and get your own
t-shirts hoodies
[Applause]